hello and welcome to yet another video
about diffusion models every time Miss
Coffee Bean thinks she's done with
covering diffusion models something new
appears on the diffusion modern Market
something so awesome she just cannot
ignore meta AI researchers have
developed a diffusion model that can
produce moving pictures so video from
text descriptions and while we were
making this video Google brain published
imagine video which is another diffusion
model that can produce video so we
quickly included that topic into this
video too the pace at which the fusion
models can generate more and more of the
visual world is mind-blowing not to
mention that they also conquered the
audio and protein realm but let's not
get distracted by other awesome
modalities because here we go today we
will explain make a video and imagine
video two diffusion models which tame
the time dimension to create not just
pictures but movies moving pictures but
before we dive in let's thank uncord the
active learning platform for computer
vision who is the sponsor of today's
video data is one of the most important
parts of creating Innovative computer
vision models The Encore platform has
been designed to make the creation of
training data and testing of machine
learning models quicker than it's ever
been
and chords does it in two ways firstly
it makes it easier to manage annotate
and evaluate training data through
collaborative annotation tools and
automation features secondly encord
offers access to its QA workflows apis
and SDK so you can create your own
Active Learning pipelines speeding up
model development
and by using Encore you don't need to
waste time building your own tools
letting you focus on getting the right
data into your models click the link to
try uncord for free great now back to
the fusion models to help wrap our heads
around this incredibly fast progress in
the diffusion models realm let's make a
timeline with some of the most important
Milestones diffused models could beat
guns on image synthesis and draw
photorealistic faces starting May 2021
already December 2021 Glide from open AI
was a diffused model that could now
generate images from text prompts in
April 2022 openai announced the
follow-up of Glide which is Dali 2. then
the option simply exploded there was
imagine from Google in May then party
also from Google in June mid-journey
entered the open Beta in July and these
models are just to name a few sorry to
everyone left out and of course there
was stable diffusion that made a huge
Splash since it is lightweight and
freely available so it can be used by
anyone unlike all of the other diffusion
models we should note that
coincidentally the day that Glide was
released was also the day that the
research paper which stands at the basis
of stable diffusion so latent diffusion
models was published on archive okay so
this timeline is just so we can better
imagine how crowded the idea space of
the fusion models is
now we can sit back and relax from the
diffusion model hype right no of course
we can't we just got used to models
creating images from text but now we
quickly move on to the space of videos
created from just the text description
video diffusion models have already been
a thing since April 2022 with very short
GIF like animations of still images the
Big Splash in video diffusion was caused
by meta AI that has shown through a
paper they haven't released a model yet
so meta AI showcases make a video a
diffusion model generating impressive
videos from text descriptions on the
29th of September 2022
okay then only a few days later October
the 5th Google research announces its
own artillery of video diffusion models
with imagine video a direct competitor
to meta ice maker video producing short
videos from text with a realism we have
not yet seen before and with finaki
capable of generating longer videos of
about two minutes the videos of anaki
are kind of creepy and not that
realistic but they are long so today we
are diving into video diffusion models
and explain how they work and in which
way make a video from meta I and imagine
video from Google differ and what they
have in common if you're not yet
familiar with how the fusion models
generate images then do check out our
previous videos on this first it is
important to understand the underlying
image mechanisms if we are to comprehend
video diffusion models because you can
think of images being videos with a
single frame for this explanation we
will assume that we already know what an
image diffusion model is we start our
explanations of text to video generators
by explaining make a video from meta AI
we choose this one for the start because
it is a special kind of video diffusion
model it is a natural enhancement of
text to image generation because it uses
text to image diffusion models to build
them in as they are for video diffusion
and since we assume we already are
familiarized with image diffusion models
make a video is a great place to start
how to generate a short video with
diffusion models the core idea of make a
video is to take a text to image
diffusion model that already knows how
the visual world looks like and what its
correspondence with text is then it
extends the text image model with video
processing snake snack and uses video
data unlabeled so unpaired to learn
realistic Motion in this way one does
not need pair text video data which
makes the training data requirements so
much better this is a way to generate
short low resolution and low frame rate
models then additional models can take
care of interpolating between frames to
increase the frame rate then super
resolution models can take care of
transforming frames into high resolution
let's take it step by step first we have
the text to image diffusion model which
shares the core components with Dali 2.
the text to image diffusion model takes
in noise and step by step it generates
images of 64 by 64 resolution it
considers the text information in the
following way the clip text encoder
embeds the text into a multimodal visual
language space a so-called prior Network
translates a text Vector into the
corresponding image Vector in the clip
embedding space
because we remember that clip was
trained to embed images and their
captions into vectors close to each
other then the diffusion model takes in
this image Vector which is a visual
equivalent of the text prompt and uses
it to gradually generate a faithful
image to the text prompt okay so this
was the Dali 2 recap in a nutshell this
takes to image diffusion model trained
on paired text image data so usually
images and their captions can now
generate pictures from text a first
super resolution Network enhances the
images to 256 squared resolution and the
second one to 768 times 768 pixels much
like Dali 2. now we are ready for the
video specific technical schnick snack
the unit producing clearer and clearer
images at each diffusion step so far had
two-dimensional convolution and
attention layers to ensure coherence in
the 2D structure of the image now for
the video the unit needs to be extended
into the temporal Dimension to ensure
temporal coherence for the convolution
layers the authors could have used 3D
convolutions but that would have been
computationally expensive so instead
they do the image like 2D convolution as
before and add a 1D convolution
following it to combine the frame frames
so the temporal Dimension this means the
network can keep all of its trained
image convolution weights and only the
one deed so the temporal convolution
layers need to be trained from scratch
cool to use the author's words at
initialization because the 1D
convolutions connecting the temporal
dimensions are random the network will
generate different images at each frame
each describing the text but lacking
temporal coherence for the attention
layers the authors do a similar thing to
the convolution especially since 3D
attention would have been even more
expensive than 3D convolutions following
each spatial attention layer which is
already there from the pre-trained text
to image unit they stack an attention
layer after the spatial attention to
combine the temporal Dimension now you
can imagine why this approach only
generated short videos as the videos
grow longer so does the number of frames
one needs to generate so the attention
window grows too so computation skills
quadratically I wonder if window
detention like in the swing Transformer
would help diminish the compute issues
here to make the generated videos have a
higher frame rates the authors use a
frame interpolation Network trained on
General video data to predict masked
frames so how is this whole thing
trained many things are trained
independently the authors train the
prior Network and the super resolution
networks on images alone they train the
text to image diffusion model on paired
text image data no fine-tuning on videos
then the authors add the video specific
convolution and attention layers and
train on unlabeled video data all in all
this work is a beast of a network that
makes clever use of existing models and
of easily available data it is easier to
find images and their captioned and
visual description of videos not
subtitles on a large scale on the
internet let's summarize make a video to
later compare it to imagine video o we
have the input text prompt and run it
through an encoder to transform it into
a vector a prior Network translates the
clip text Vector into the corresponding
clip image Vector then a base diffusion
model which was first trained to
generate images from text just like
tally 2 gets additional convolution and
attention layers onto the temporal
Dimension to combine different frames
into a video a temporal super resolution
network does frame interpolation so it
increases the temporal resolution by
producing more and more frames in
between frames then two spatial super
resolution models upscale the individual
frames to increase the resolution of the
video frame by frame now we know how
make a video works now let's look at
Google's approach how does Imagine video
generate videos with diffusion
to put it this way what would we need to
change and make a video to make imagine
video we would need to change this
Cascade of diffusion models to end up
with a Cascade of seven diffusion models
first we would need to replace the text
encoder by a frozen T5 XXL text
Transformer which was trained on lots
and lots of text only data then a little
different is how the base video
diffusion model is trained
architecturally it is also a unit
enhanced with temporal attention and
temporal convolutions to bind the
individual images together which are a
part of the same video it is basically
the training of this that differs
between imagine video and make a video
the authors train it on images and video
simultaneously where they treat single
images as single frame videos but this
means that for the video training data
they do need aligned video and text
description which means that they use a
Google internal data set for this while
May make a video got away without a line
text video data the story continues like
for imagine with a temporal super
sampling Network that produces more
frames it is followed by two spatial
super resolution models like with make a
video but then we have two more temporal
up sampling models to produce more
frames than yet another spatial super
sampling and done this is in a nutshell
the raw difference between imagine video
and make a video and with classifier
free guidance which we covered in
another video and with some other little
tricks this Cascade of seven models just
seems to work which must be a great
achievement for the authors since this
paper on imagined video is a direct
follow-up of their previous work on the
fusion models marking the territory in
diffusion modeling in their previous
work they were proving the concept that
the fusion models are possible by
producing 64 frames of 128 times 128
pixels at 24 frames per second
now imagine video can do 128 frames long
HD videos also at 24 frames per second
the multitude of ways to do and to
combine things in the diffusion model
space and the lack of insight for why a
thing works and in which constellation
it doesn't makes it so hard to wrap Miss
coffee Bean's head around this her
hypothesis is that nobody knows why
diffusion models work and which
combination of Tricks is the best and
why tricks to the trick in the first
place
if you're interested in even more video
diffusion models to check out finaki
which is also a video diffusion model
published the same day as imagine video
from another group at Google capable of
producing long video where of course the
realism suffers a bit at this kind of
length Miss Coffee Bean cannot wait to
see what kind of long and realistic
videos will come out of the diffusion
models of the next three months what do
you think of this diffusion model flurry
how are you going to use them in your
work and everyday life we hope to read
from you in the comments see you in the
next video
bye
[Music]